hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
november 8 2020 what's going on
how are you how's it going
um how are you how's it going i got
great news
i got up some tour dates coming up i'm
[ __ ] i'm getting back out there again
doing some covid
safe which all comes down to you guys
how you behave at the shows but i mean
we're doing our best to make sure you
[ __ ] animals
behave the way you're supposed to well
where you gonna be bill
i'm going to the great state of texas
um wednesday december 2nd
i will be in the city that killed john f
kennedy
dallas texas um at the a t
performing
uh in annette strauss square and on
friday december 4th
i'll be in austin texas home of the
dirty white hippies
in texas they make them all go there so
they don't have to look at them
in respectable parts of texas
um i'll be uh let's see friday december
4th
austin texas there you go and
uh on sunday uh december
6th i'm gonna be
in houston texas at the white oak
music hall um houston texas
home of the shiny never seen the
off-road
or or or a hard day's work four-door
um pickup truck i've never seen so many
shiny [ __ ] pickup trucks that
literally look like they just came right
off the showroom
i don't know people just like i gotta
have a truck you gotta have a truck in
texas
gotta wear a big 10 gallon i didn't have
a truck um
but personally i love trucks i saw one
today that um
it was basically the sister or the
brother to my truck it was a 67 or 68
f-100 and it was in that wimbledon white
that ford had back in the day
and um you know if i was an idiot
you know but i just kept buying
everything that i [ __ ] ever want i
would i would get that truck too and
then i have a black one and a white one
because i can't make up my mind which
one i like better
i love them both um that's the kind of
dumb [ __ ] i would do i would have
i would have a uh
just i think i'm mainly a truck guy i
think i would just have trucks and i
would have some of those
uh you know the 1980s the 80 to 86
front end ford bronco the full-size one
two-tone
um i definitely have
an f250 high boy and i'd have one with
the front end from
74 what is it 72 to 77 or whatever that
front end i'd have that one
i'm not into the sanford and sun ones
you know i like them but
every time i look at one somebody
[ __ ]
i don't know they redid the inside and i
just don't like it i hate when they do
that [ __ ]
they put that stupid steering wheel and
those dumb [ __ ] round breaks not the
round breaks those the original ones the
whatever bill you're off the rails all
right so i got some dates okay we're
gonna see how these things sell and then
you know uh
maybe i'll i'll get my ass out there to
texas three cities
the big ones dallas houston and austin i
know there's another big one in there
isn't there
is el paso here's where
uh the uh texas tech is lupic
um i don't know all i know is whenever i
drive from dallas
down to [ __ ] uh austin
or um houston or the other way around
i drive up somewhere along the way is
some [ __ ] place you got to stop at
it's right near waco texas that has
these little pastries with like meat in
them that i believe some sort of eastern
european thing they were part of the
communist bloc i don't know who the f
you know i should look that [ __ ] up
right now
the [ __ ] is it called um
i'm gonna look up check meet
pi uh
waco waco
no waco texas let's see where that gets
me
uh check check stop
how many years check stop it i think
this is it
that's it yeah that place checked up
i'm gonna be [ __ ] head over there and
eat a bunch of calories i don't need to
eat but whatever i don't go there a lot
i don't go there a lot all right let's
get on with the podcast here
let's talk what happened in this country
this week there's only one
the biggest news story in the country
what do you got nfl football week
[ __ ] eight
or is it nine i have no ideas no idea
ideas um i barely watched any goddamn
football
today i watched a little bit of the
raiders the las vegas raid is coming to
be
coming back again against the chargers
everybody's going to get down on the
chargers
they're scoring all kinds of points they
just can't seem to quite [ __ ]
hold them off um at the end of the
goddamn game
and um i don't know what it is i don't
know why
i don't know why but um are they
actually gonna let me watch this there's
a little bit left
you [ __ ] [ __ ] sucker you got me
um there's a little bit of time left in
the steelers cowboys game cowboys had
the ball
oh my god i tell you what the dumb is
this why i don't [ __ ] gamble
you know i try to i was gambling earlier
this year with my boogie out of [ __ ]
doing
and uh you know i'm just the worst so
this was my big goddamn pick
my my my pick six of the [ __ ] week
that's how i pick games
i i was convinced the seattle seahawks
were not only going to beat the buffalo
bills i'm like they're going to kick the
[ __ ] out of them
i feel like the bills had a a record
that was better than they actually were
they hadn't faced any sort of uh real
tests
and i believed in pete carroll and uh i
saw a whole thing
pregame about russell wilson and that dk
metcalf you know practicing
before the season trying to get on the
same page do some montana jerry right
[ __ ] i'm like oh my god this is going to
be [ __ ] unbelievable and what ends up
happening
the bills dropped 44 [ __ ] points
on the seattle seahawks and
uh win the game 44-34
shows you what the hell i know but i
taped that game i taped the chiefs
panthers another great one
and um then of course i got to watch
gardner minshew i taped his [ __ ] game
whatever game that was who the hell were
they playing texans jaguars
um jags lose by two i'm telling you
seahawks and the [ __ ] jags have
scored more goddamn points and not won a
[ __ ] game
they you know they're a couple of pieces
away being really good the new york
football giants own
absolutely own what the washington
football club
whatever they call themselves they they
[ __ ] swept
the season series 2-0 you want to play
at home
you want to play in washington it
doesn't matter the new york football
giants own
the the washington football team you
know other than that they lose every
week but they're
they're in transition just like
everybody in the nfc east
it's just a weird time where everybody
seems to either have an injury
injury or a new quarterback or a [ __ ]
uh
rookie quarterback or a whole new coach
or whatever
um anyway what else happened this week
nothing really happened sort of a boring
[ __ ] week
i know you know what i did election
night i didn't watch it i didn't watch
a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
second of it
i didn't i was just like i'm just gonna
wait did they tell me
who's gonna win this [ __ ] thing all
right i don't want to sit here on pins
and needles losing my [ __ ] mind
are we going to get rid of this [ __ ]
guy is he here is this new [ __ ] guy
who kind of can speak in completed
sentences is he going to be the new guy
what's gonna [ __ ] happen and yada
yada yada yada i was like i'm not
getting into that [ __ ] so i mean i was
also convinced
i lost big money i already owed [ __ ]
keith robinson
money on the super bowl still haven't
paid him
i ran into him over though back in the
year i should have paid him then but i
didn't i just
had been so long because i was going to
pay him because i was going to see him
and then the whole [ __ ] covert thing
happened
all right i'm not a welcher so
um we would talk on the election so
i was like how about double or nothing
because he was like he's like
he goes trump ain't gonna win stupid i
go he's gonna win
i know he's gonna win and you go all
right i gotta hop a double or nothing on
what i owe you on the super bowl i owed
him 400 bucks
that couldn't have just been the suit i
think i lost two bets in a rowdom couple
hundred each and then i was down 400
bucks right
so i go double or nothing i go all in on
donnie
you know i go all in on donald trump
and the [ __ ] guy loses and now i'm
out eight hundred dollars
eight hundred bucks and it when it gets
to that number i i gotta send i gotta
wire him the money or whatever
you know you owe somebody 50 bucks i'm
400 bucks i should have paid him by now
but you know
keith keith is he's too nice for this
[ __ ] money collection business um
i gotta pay him so anyway um out here in
la
when they finally declared biden a
winner at least in the liberal part of
los
angeles because in beverly hills they
weren't they were riding around with
trump signs and [ __ ]
and then over in like liberal areas the
liberals were out
like literally dancing in the street and
uh it was disappointing
it's like have you learned nothing
they're so [ __ ] dumb
everybody everybody's just dumb now when
it comes to politics
you're acting like your team won the
super bowl and now
you're gonna [ __ ] go online or
whatever and you're gonna go [ __ ] on
you know you know people do that you
know
nice try wisconsin you know whatever the
[ __ ] they do well that's not a city
you know whatever [ __ ] you kansas city
or some [ __ ] that you do after your team
wins a game
they're doing that and people are
forgetting that we're all on the same
[ __ ] team here
and um i i
really don't understand what i
understand part of it i mean we
basically
as far as i can tell i'm not i'm not a
big politic guy i'm not the smartest guy
in the [ __ ] room
as far as i can tell we got rid of a
racist [ __ ]
to we replaced them with the warmonger
with dementia
or the beginning of it something is what
they're saying there's something going
on with this guy mentally
um so i don't know what everybody's so
like like people on the left remember
how funny it was when you saw people on
the right dancing in the street thinking
that trump was gonna make it better he's
gonna make it great again like whatever
the [ __ ] that meant
and you just thought they were so
[ __ ] stupid you guys are doing the
exact
same [ __ ] thing you're doing the same
thing like your life i mean i
i kind of get it because trump was
uh really race-baiting there
which was [ __ ] horrible i get that
aspect of it but as far as how we're
gonna get out of this
this debt that we're in i don't [ __ ]
know so i don't know hopefully
i don't know you know jesus christ
what are we gonna do here one of these
two people who are now in they're just
gonna [ __ ] put everybody in jail it
seems to be what they like to do i don't
know
i have no [ __ ] idea i just i just
would just like uh people to get along
again
and stop looking at the government like
they're your parents and when there's a
mess you got to look at them to [ __ ]
clean it up when
we have a lot of power as regular people
don't we to try and
make your little area better i don't
[ __ ] know i have no
[ __ ] idea um what's going to happen
but what i am settling in for right now
is
now the show begins because
boy the courts are calling
he's going to [ __ ] sue
and and then just the the the wrath
of his lame duckness is gonna be i think
it's gonna be to a
whole other [ __ ] level and i am in a
blue state so i am [ __ ] putting
i'm sandbags sandbags up against the
front doors of my bank
because i have a feeling he's gonna
[ __ ] empty him out
um yeah it's uh
it's really crazy and um
i don't know and i don't even know where
i stand politically i just know that i
don't like i didn't like any of the [ __ ]
that's uh
i was joking with the buddy of mine um
it's [ __ ] hilarious he's one of those
you know those people who just say
they're an independent i'm a registered
independent but then like they always
argue one side or the other so you're
like okay so you're a control freak you
don't like to be labeled but it's clear
so this guy's clearly a staunch
republican right
so he was all upset because can you
believe these
left-wing people these liberals it's
like i get it you won but you know what
the [ __ ] it's just like you see the
stuff that they're posting
and i was just like well i thought you
were independent isn't happy you
half of you very excited about what's
going on i just kept breaking his balls
and i finally just said to him
you know i dream of the day when some
well you trust me enough as a friend to
be like bill
i am a staunch republican at which point
i can then say buddy
there's nothing wrong with that
so he laughed and then continued on
claiming that he was an independent
and then i just and as he continued to
flip out because i remember when
trump got elected
i mean i'm not gonna lie to you i was
laughing my ass off watching all of
those people crying
it was [ __ ] hilarious watching adults
crying
it was just funny and um
i don't know i just thought it was
[ __ ] funny to me i mean i you know
who knew what the [ __ ] trump was i mean
oh this guy's going to do he's going to
you know what the [ __ ] somebody's going
to do it was just funny to me
and um
i don't know and then this this time
around just watching uh so i
what i'm trying my mind's all over the
place here sorry
so i was sitting there going like dude i
[ __ ] kind of rubbed it in two
when trump won i enjoyed
i enjoyed that right and now i'm
enjoying biden winning and watching
trump people be upset
and i kind of realize that i i think
politically i am part of the contrarian
party
[Laughter]
and i hate this about myself but happy
people annoy me
seeing those liberals dancing annoyed me
watching
the [ __ ] he's going make great again
those [ __ ] people celebrating that
annoyed me
um i don't even think i'm into politics
i just think i'm like this crabby old
man yeah what are you dancing for
it's [ __ ] stupid i will tell you a
[ __ ]
low point though is when anderson
cooper when he said trump is in the
white house
like a fat turtle laying on his back
it's just like
what you're not even a journalist
you're like a [ __ ] youtube commenter
like
i i don't understand people why do you
watch cnn why do you watch fox news
i think at this point like to people
that is news i i know i've been talking
about this forever i just don't
understand i really think
they should get rid the both of those
channels need to be broken up
they need to break up the [ __ ]
internet
or like i don't know
i i i i just the
the [ __ ] the fact that there's no
libel
or anything like that on the internet
and you can just present everything
as fact is really just [ __ ] everybody
up and like
the number one thing that i heard during
this election was i don't know what to
believe
and uh i always use the analogy of the
[ __ ] egg
you know go on the internet and i want
you to definitively find information
that lets me know it
is this good for me or is it bad because
in my lifetime it has changed like you
know eggs were good for you
then they became bad for a while
and everybody started doing the egg
white omelets and then there was this
big push coming back saying no man the
proteins in the yolk
it's in the yolk and then people got
back into them again and then somewhere
in the middle of all that people started
drinking butter
or melting it and pouring it into their
[ __ ] coffee
and then there was uh and then i think
they're bad again
so i have no [ __ ] idea
anyways so here we go my condolences to
everybody who loved trump
sorry you guys didn't win
congratulations to the biden people
that your person won um
i think that it's incredibly ignorant as
an american right now to rub it in uh
on the to the to right wing people that
that guy
lost i think it's incredibly childish to
go after trump
and make all these stupid [ __ ] memes
everybody needs to chill out and be nice
and you know maybe treat people with
respect
and uh once again it's it's everybody
has
balls on the internet you know and and
they just
the the level of just rude that they
behave
you know i got a lot of balls
considering the [ __ ] podcast i do but
i'm just saying it would be nice
if uh you know we went back to a world
where you don't bring up
politics and religion when you go to a
party
and [ __ ] like that it would kind of be
nice and i don't know if you could maybe
extend that
to your social media comments which i
know you're not going to
because i don't know it is fun to
[ __ ] annoy people but
um i will tell you that that is going to
be uh
i don't i i have this feeling that trump
is going to be
he's going to go isaiah thomas when he's
got to turn the keys over
when when [ __ ] the pistons lost to
the bulls i think
he might do that i don't think he's
going to i think he's going to get
advised
not to do that um
but having said that you know you got to
hand it to trump unbelievable success
story
the fact that that guy was brought to a
roast he was invited
to a roast where he discovered that he
was the raw meat
you know there's always that person on
every roast every roast is a person who
gets invited
and is excited going wow i can't believe
those guys thought of me
and then they get in there and it's like
oh oh [ __ ] i'm the giant [ __ ]
salt licking i'm basically there's
always there's one person who gets
invited because
we're all going to make fun of the same
person and the later you go in the roast
the less jokes
are left so what you do is you have you
bring in some [ __ ] crazy person
or some person that you know people
consider crazy i should say and then
they end up getting it a lot of times
worse
than the uh the person getting roasted
so when they [ __ ] brought in
you know donald trump on that [ __ ]
presidential whatever the hell the thing
the one that seth meyers did and they
stuck him in the middle of the [ __ ]
room
and oh my god did he get [ __ ] lit up
and he got belittled and was made fun of
and obama like obama of all the [ __ ]
since john f kennedy i haven't seen a
guy deliver a punch line the way that
guy that guy's timing
i got to give it up was [ __ ] amazing
and
um they made fun of donald about his
day-to-day
versus what the actual president did
and within like a year and a half of
that
that [ __ ] guy who you thought was a
boob
ran for president and [ __ ] won and
you had to turn your keys over to him
now say what you want about the guy but
that is like that's like a hollywood
ending
i mean they treated him like carrie at
the [ __ ] prom
he dumped the pig blood on him and the
[ __ ] guy came back you know
i mean i wasn't a fan of what he did
when he was in there but
you know you got to give it up right
you got to give it up most people won't
but you got to that that was an amazing
turn of events um
so anyway uh so now we got this guy in
so i imagine
uh if i was living in the middle east i
would be nervous
um i don't know i don't know what the
you know what's for [ __ ] that's how
much these [ __ ] wars cost this
goddamn country
you could literally buy everybody in
this country
okay you could buy [ __ ] everybody at
tesla and put
solar panels on top of everybody's house
or apartment building
we could totally wean down the amount of
oil that we use
and have to buy from the middle east at
which point
there would no longer be a focus of our
[ __ ] corporations
and then when we pull out they can go
back to
politely discussing kidding they can go
back to [ __ ] dealing with each other
right
and they won't have all that oil money
from us to funnel
through the the moss over there to give
to terrorist groups to fight us now they
don't need to fight us anymore because
we'll be gone
and then nobody has to die and you don't
have to drop a bomb to try to get the
bad guy but you actually
accidentally killed a baby and then that
baby's brother grows up to want to
[ __ ] kill an american
you could do that i don't i know i'm
over simplifying this [ __ ] but i don't
know why we just don't do that
um because this hoe going around the
world and putting our foot in the back
of people's necks and trying to force
them to do what the [ __ ] we want i don't
i don't
i don't know it's been good for
corporations i guess all right i'm i'm
getting outside my [ __ ] pay grade
here but uh
i like to float [ __ ] out there ideas
that i have
you know and you know what else i don't
know anything about solar power or how
much oil
is probably needed to uh i don't know
grease those things or some [ __ ] to put
them up on a roof i don't [ __ ] enough
none of this is researched you know but
this is the internet you know
um am i the only person that if somebody
writes wash me on my car
i i could literally in that moment if i
found the person murder them
stab them [ __ ] repeatedly um
the [ __ ] balls of somebody to come
out that just basically happened to a
friend's
friend of mine's car somebody wrote
something really [ __ ] pretentious
about you know at least they did it on
the window if you're one of those [ __ ]
that does that
um when you do that on the paint the
dirt that's on there will scratch the
paint
you [ __ ] idiot and then also writing
wash me is not original
but it's just the fact that somebody
put their hands on something that you
won't there's something about that i
don't know what it is
um i wonder if there's any videos of
that is there any video of that somebody
just getting slapped
uh person wash
me car
karma see what we get here
karma car wash oh jesus i missed out on
that
all right knocked out oh that came up
that came up wait a minute wait a minute
details no
please wash me car wash no videos come
on
dancing boxer learns about karma oh yeah
that's a classic one
car wash theme song car wash employee
taken for a ride
man slashes tire but suffers instant
karma for this
that's not what i was looking for um
anyway uh so yeah so my buddy called me
up and he was all pissed watching all
these liberals celebrate which was funny
to me
because we were both laughing and and
finger-pointing when trump got in i
thought it was [ __ ] hilarious
uh it quickly wasn't but it was funny
um it reminded me when the red sox
finally beat the yankees and then won
the world series and regis philbin of
all people
was who's a yankees fan he goes he's
like i get it you won the world series
okay now shut up about it
he wanted us to be all classy after
those [ __ ] [ __ ] were chanting
1918 in our face forever
and got the red they we showed it on tv
and the whole [ __ ]
league was doing it and all these
[ __ ] yankee fans oh i'm happy i'm
happy for you guys i know you're not you
just don't want to take your [ __ ]
medicine
so i found all of that [ __ ] uh i find
all of that [ __ ] to be uh
to be fascinating but i i'm telling you
right now what i'm really rooting for
somehow i'm rooting against you know i
just want people to just stop being
[ __ ] to each other
and um i definitely as you can tell i
lean
left it's weird i was brought up
republican
and then i became liberal and then
somewhere i don't know where i am i'm
sort of like
all over the map but i i i'm
conservative with a lot of [ __ ]
but when it comes to giving people a
chance
who don't look like me i'm all for that
so that's where i get liberal
i have a liberal attitude towards that
i'm not saying that but you know
if you're a republican automatically
you're a racist but i just sort of
[ __ ] lean
um that way like i don't give a [ __ ] if
a dude wants to wear a dress
to [ __ ] work it doesn't bother me
it's like can you do the job
all right fine
i don't give a [ __ ] um
but then i'm conservative with like
other stuff as far as like parenting and
[ __ ] like
you know getting your kid a [ __ ]
phone like what are they running a
business
um and i am also conservative when i
look at the internet the fact that you
know they
the fact that the second a little kid
gets a phone they can watch a beheading
video or some
[ __ ] up porn is just i like the fact
that there's nothing to stop that is
just
[ __ ] mind-boggling to me out of all
this [ __ ]
you know people get [ __ ] upset about
or whatever
you know i watch chappelle on uh snl i'm
sure he's getting
some [ __ ] it just seems like people get
outraged by that but
for some reason it's okay
you know for kids to see that and
there's the level of psychological
damage that that's
that's when i get like conservative
that's when i that's when i [ __ ] tuck
my shirt in and i pull my pants up but
other than that i don't know
i don't know yeah christ i'm babbling
here all right let's get to the uh
let's get to the reason hey it's my
bookie hey how the [ __ ] you doing
whatever you got you guys want to win
some money on my bookie
bet the exact opposite way i have been
i'm gonna start publishing my picks
right before the one o'clock kickoff
then you guys just do the exact ops i am
getting [ __ ] destroyed this year
seattle's going to destroy buffalo are
they bill
all right my bookie you know late fall
college ball
the nba bubble and ufc fight island it's
clear
2020 has been a year unlike any other
which is why you need a sports book
with offers which offers with offers
unlike any other
get some skin in the game with my bookie
where odds boosts
um lightning deals and free bets await
all season long and with turkey day
right around the corner there is really
no better time to feast on some nfl
action
whether you're a first-time customer or
have been playing with my bookie for
years there is no
shortage of value to be found in
thousands of game lines unique prop bets
and contests
that they offer every week sign up or
get relocated today
find an edge make your bet and get paid
they also boost
boast sorry a fully fledged casino
platform
giving you access to all the classic
table slot and card games you'd expect
to find you at your local spot
this is a one-stop gambling uh
utopia and the best part is that my
bookie
the doors never close so you can
continue to build your bankroll even
after the stadium lights have gone out
make the right play and sign up today at
my bookie and when you do
use promo code burr burr to get your
deposit matched halfway um
all the way up to a thousand bucks let
me read that again to get your deposit
matched
halfway all the way up to a thousand
bucks
the terms are simple you put in 200
bucks they'll match you with another 100
in your account all the way up to a
thousand bucks if you're already we're
already planning to bet this season
this is free betting money uh it's a
it's winning season at my bookies so
come join in on the fun
and win some cash while you're while
you're at it
oh look who it is everybody would you
look who it is it's the candid company
candid co uh you know all the things
we'd love to do for ourselves but
haven't done it
but i haven't done it for some reason
well if you've always wanted to
straighten your teeth
and a better smile stop putting it off
thanks to candid
straightening your teeth is simpler
easier and more comfortable than ever
candy clear aligners are comfortable and
removable and practically invisible
unlike wire braces so you can transform
your smile without anyone noticing
plus your treatment is prescribed and
monitored remotely by a licensed
orthodontist
who's an expert in tooth movement all of
it's done
from the comfort and convenience of your
own home candid only works with
orthodontics orthodontists never
general dentists like other companies uh
plus you're supervised oh that shots
fired right there they just got goddamn
general dentist over there
we have orthodontists the specialists
all right would you have your uncle come
over and just [ __ ] you know put some
braces on your teeth you want an
orthodontist
plus your supervising orthodontist will
be with you every step of the way
with candid your treatment includes
remote monitoring by
by the same orthodontist who created
your plan so you never have to wonder
how you're doing you'll always know the
average candid treatment is just six
months
you'll start seeing results way before
then and it costs thousands
less than braces uh start straightening
your teeth today right now all listeners
can save 75 dollars on candid starter
kits
go to canadaco.com
and use the code bur burr that's candid
co
dot com uh slash burr code bird take
advantage of this limited time offer to
save 75
on your static kit candid co
dot com slash bur code bur all right oh
look who it is everybody
manscaped huh support for the monday
morning podcast is brought to you by
manscaped who is the best in men's
below-the-waist grooming
manscaped is taking over the world and
is now available in all of europe
canada the uk and australia the world is
about to get a lot less hairy
that's right folks you can now purchase
manscape products
if you haven't had to well you know
something i wonder if they have
different attachments for different
parts of the world
you know there's hairier and less
hairier people around the world
some places in the world we got our new
back [ __ ]
trimmer um the world is about to get a
lot less hairy that's right folks you
can now purchase manscape products if
you haven't
uh had access to man's case thus far
you're go uh you've gone years without
using the right tools for the job if you
haven't tried their lawn
mower 3.0 the electric trimmer has been
uh you've been missing out this is one
of the greatest
ball hair trimmers on the planet
according to rogan
joe rogan and god knows he's tried a lot
of ball hair trimmers so if joe rogan
says it's great i i
support that message uh their third
generation trimmer features
the a cutting-edge ceramic blade to
reduce
grooming accidents jesus christ grooming
accidents uh
keeping your nuts smooth like a baby's
butt
what um have you tried their wee weed
whacker nose and ear trimmer
no wait nose and ear hair trimmer but
you know what the [ __ ] crazy thing is
about nose hair
is you don't see it until the thing's
sticking like an inch out of your nose
it's like ah i need a haircut you just
never see it and then all of a sudden
you're brushing your teeth like what in
the [ __ ] is that how long i've been
walking around with that
um you can now keep your nose maybe
because it gets stuck up in the nostril
it gets so long at one point it just
goes dwing and just kind of sticks out
is that what it does i don't know you
can now keep your nose
and ear hair looking as nice as your
clean shaven pubes 79 of partners polled
admitted that
long nose hair is a major turn off so
it's time to get to whacking but what's
wrong with those other 21 percent of
people that long nose hairs doesn't turn
them off
bill let's try not to judge okay both of
these flagship items come inside the
manscapes performance package
along with other quality products like
their athletic boxer briefs
you can now reach peak performance
easily with the performance package
let's get that bush to touch clean so
you can be prepared at all times get 20
percent off and free shipping
with the code bur 20 at manscape.com
manscape is my new best friend get 20
off and free shipping with the code bur
burr 20
burr 2-0 at manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping with codebird20
manscape.com
your balls will thank you
your balls will thank you all right
stamps.com
uh the holiday season whooby dooby do uh
more people will be mailing stuff
than ever before that means the post
office is going to be busy
you don't have time for that [ __ ]
stamps.com brings the post office and
now ups shipping right to your computer
mail and ship anything from the
convenience of your home or
officewithstamps.com anything you do
with the post office you can do just
in a few clicks at home or at your
office plus stamps.com
saves you money with deep discounts that
you can't even get at the post office
you've heard me talk about stamps.com
they've been sponsoring the show for
over seven years now and if you haven't
tried it what are you waiting for
simply use your computer to print
official u.s postage 24 7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send
once your mail is ready just schedule a
pickup or drop it off that's that simple
with stamps.com you get five five
cents off every first class stamping up
to forty percent off priority mail and
up to sixty two percent off you
ups shipping rates stamps.com is a
no-brainer saving you time and money
it's no wonder over nine hundred
thousand small businesses already use
stamps.com don't spend a minute of your
holiday season at the post office this
year
sign up for stamps.com instead there's
no risk
with promo code burr burr you get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial
plus free shipping sorry plus free
postage and a digital scale not free
shipping free postage and a digital
digital scale
no long-term commitments or contract
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in burr burr that stamps dot
com enter burst stamps.com
never go to the post office again
um all right plowing ahead here
all right what do we got here i got some
uh
i got some reeds here oh i got a bunch
of stuff i got reeds i got top
five you know your top five dumb
questions if you work with the public
that people have asked you
and i always throw myself right on the
[ __ ]
i jump right on the grenade as always i
always mention this
i went to
[Music]
joshua tree and i asked the park ranger
where is the joshua tree
which for those of you on the east coast
like where i'm from that's like being in
new hampshire
and asking somebody where is the elm
tree
all right other fans from egypt oh [ __ ]
i might have to do comedy cairo coming
up hey billy you
bald-headed [ __ ] i love it i love that
there's somebody in egypt
that has a sense of humor like that god
bless you i'm 26 years i'm a 26 year old
guy from egypt
i heard on your latest your last episode
about the egyptian
architect that listened to 12 years of
monday morning podcast in six months
i also graduated as an architect and
your podcast was like my friend
during my sleepless studying days who
would have thought my dumb ass podcast
is helping architects
over in egypt and i listen to you
hey i got a dumb question for you i got
a touristy question for you
as far as the pyramids go so when you're
when you're an architect
you you must study the pyramids is part
of any of your
uh training do you have to design a
pyramid or is that just the
dumbest is that like you saying hey
you're an american and you're an
architect school
do you have to design a [ __ ] i don't
know what uh
uh goddamn i don't know mcdonald's sign
or some [ __ ] i'm trying to think of
something
what is taurus do you have to design a
statue of liberty
no france did that i don't [ __ ] know
um and i listen to you now as i work as
an interior designer
i just want to thank you for the laughs
no worry he goes i just want to teach
you some egyptian cuss words you can use
uh i hope i say this right uh cos omac
c-o-s space o-m-a-k
castle mack that means your mother's
[ __ ]
uh eben shamorta
your mother is a [ __ ] or a [ __ ]
that's weird because kos omak and eben
shimota there's no
they both have mother in it i don't see
any similarity there
um it seems like a difficult language i
don't know how to pronounce it that's
that's one eben
gleben uh eben charmota
ebn space s-h-a-r-m-o-t-a
all right that's good to know
i don't know which one of those i would
use if i went over there
all right your mother's a [ __ ] um i
would say that if they drop me off too
far away
that's that's the tough one though is
that like go [ __ ] yourself over there i
have no idea i'm just psyched people
from egypt are listening
anwar sadat one of my favorite uh world
leaders when i was a kid
i saw him give a speech outside the
white house during the reagan years all
right your stance on violence
uh dear billy bill people in the comm in
comment section
sometimes speak for you uh according to
them
you're both an alt-right misogynist and
a lib as well as a liberal douche
that warms my heart i love that people
in la think i voted for trump
people in [ __ ] a red state think uh
you know i'm a biden guy or whatever um
this isn't new at all i've seen people
[ __ ] up
categorizing you for a while yeah i'm
part of the contrarian party
uh one argument that was interesting was
whether or not you condone violence
against trump supporters i don't condone
violence against anybody
um i voted for joey no pulse
[Laughter]
you know we'll say this about [ __ ]
joe biden he's already getting some
great nicknames forgetful freddie that
was mine
joey no pulse uh
bloodless magoo i mean the guy's he's
the he's like
i don't know all right let's just let's
just powerhead here um i voted for joey
no pulse
but i'm also not going to sucker punch
my
uncle for voting for trump uh do you
agree with this non-violent stance
for the commenters at home thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself um
i'm only getting half the story here and
all of a sudden you're getting do i agr
do you
no i don't condone attacking people for
their political beliefs i don't condone
bringing politics up when people are
just at a party trying to have a good
time
although i am guilty of doing that um
and it's always something i i literally
just overheard and didn't research
um but you know that is the internet the
internet is you can just say whatever
you want and say
people go on and you know they do
reviews of my act and they say what i
meant
by jokes they say why my jokes work and
i look at them and they're hilarious
because none of it is right none of it
makes any [ __ ] sense
and they're not comedians and they're
just speaking see the reason why this
joke worked is because of x y and z
what he's saying with this joke it's
just like you know you oh you could just
[ __ ] ask me i could give you
definitively well
why why do i need to ask him i have all
the answers
um all right future government oh boy
oh boy this is going to get this is
going to get deep here future government
um which by the way it actually rained
out here i was excited about that
rained out here it's getting cold for la
anyway
and um that's a great thing
you know we i think we got by the fire
month i believe i don't know but i
thought the santa ana winds were still
coming but maybe a little bit of rain
will help people out um
i don't know we shall see um all right
but god bless anybody out there who's
actually starting a company that's gonna
try to battle
uh global warming as opposed to ignoring
it um
hey you guys send me in some companies
that are into that [ __ ] if you guys
have any and i won't research it and
then i'll just read it as fact does that
sound cool all right future government
everybody
dear billy doomsday have you been
following along with this
back better thing no
do i want to it's a phrase that started
showing up
on the platforms of candidates around
the world
a few basic google searches and you can
find where the money comes from
it's basically a collection of huge tech
companies
coming together with government agencies
to transform society
all right into something better
i don't remember voting for this nor
have i seen
much about this on the news well they
never let you vote for any of this [ __ ]
i'll probably help pay for it through
though like the rest of us suckers they
don't seem to be releasing much
information
just vague initiatives about how to
spend money to make things better
do you think they'll be taking
suggestions from average joes like
us on this better future does a guy who
hates street level
computing worry about stuff like this
um thanks and keep plowing ahead um
listen i know where i fit into [ __ ] and
i
i am not the guy that's going to solve
problems so there's
just people that are a level of smart
that i don't think an average person
like myself can understand and it's up
to them
to use their my gift is i tell [ __ ]
jokes that is my gift i come to town i
do my jokes i jump up and down and make
an ass of myself and you guys laugh and
hopefully forget about your problems for
an hour right
that's my job that's what i'm good at
there's super smart people that actually
can probably help solve a lot of the
problems that we have
and um so
i'm i'm hoping that that is going to be
that they've put that together i just i
mean that that is an unholy
matrimony right there huge tech
companies which seem to own a lot of the
social media i just feel uh i don't know
i don't know that seems like cameras
i'm sure they're going to sell it like
this will
i will say if there is a if there's a
way to start
cert stop certain kinds of crimes and
they just use it for that but you know
they'll go beyond that
you know if there's a way to stop like
kidnappings and rapes and murders and
people getting
you know hurt and stuff like that
if they can use technology for that and
the environment i'm all for that but i
don't know i yeah i i would definitely
be
nervous about where they're going with
that but
i don't know if you want to have more
freedom uh make less people
you know it's when you seven billion
we're going to go for 8 billion
they're just going to put us in
stockades at some point i mean how are
you going to keep all those people
you know but back in the day when there
was just a couple million people you
just [ __ ] walk around you didn't need
an id you could do whatever the [ __ ] you
wanted to do
um all right sinkhole that almost made
sense what i just said all right
sinkhole hey bill did you hear about
this guy
man falls into pit filled with rats
after sinkhole
opens on new york city sidewalk oh my
god
did you ever worry about them when you
were living in new york you know what i
don't
i don't um walk on those subway grates
and i don't uh drive over you know when
they're
putting up a big building and they have
those
you know so they got to put you know the
sewage everyone's going to take a [ __ ]
in that building where is it going to go
we got we got to put it where the
dolphins are
so um they always you know they got to
do some
work under the streets you know when
they're in the process of building that
stuff connecting it up to the
the sewer line or whatever they'll have
a hole and they'll have that giant
metal grate that they put i won't drive
my car over that if i can avoid it and
if i
if i can't then
um you know i do what i can oh my god
that hole is so small
what in the [ __ ]
one man will have nightmare fuel to last
him a lifetime
after new york city sidewalk opened up
beneath his feet plunging him into an
underground
vault filled with rats dirty
furry scrabbling hungry rats oh my god
that's like some indiana jones [ __ ]
wait a second you guys want to hear this
this is way more interesting than i'll
ever be hold on a second let's get back
to the beginning of this video
police say the victim was transported to
saint barnabas hospital
oh forget it i thought they were talking
to the guy he was in stable condition
the horrifying incident happened on
saturday october 24th near a bus stop in
the bronx
surveillance video shows leonard 33 was
waiting at the stop when a sinkhole
opened beneath him dropping him
3.7 meters to 4.6 okay that's 12 to 15
feet
down into a rat's layer it's like he
didn't break his legs on that fall
um in other news two murder hornet
queens
captured in washington state sting
what enough that's really clever writing
there uh he went down
feet first his mother cindy white told
nbc he was just standing
and the sidewalk just it was like a
suction like a sinkhole he just went
down
shoulders face shoulders face scraped
the concrete as he fell
and he hurt his leg and arm on the way
down his brother told
cbs new york but that wasn't the worst
of it
shoulders found himself alone in the
dark
with the teeming hoard of vermin unable
to escape a call for help he ultimately
spent 30
minutes in the chamber with the rats
rats crawling on him
he can't move he just it was so bad his
brother said
he didn't want to yell because he was
afraid they were going to be rats inside
his mouth
oh my god bystanders called for help but
it took some time for the firefighters
to pull
shoulders oh he didn't scrape his
shoulder sure this is his name
i thought he was saying he scraped his
shoulders his name is shoulders
shoulders face scraped the concrete i
guess shoulders shoulders were okay
one witness said he looked in the hole
and the guy was only moving his hands
video which i will not watch shows
shoulders being carted away on a
stretcher after the ordeal
he was taken to a hospital for treatment
and was still there on thursday
he's traumatized his mother said he said
he went straight down and he was falling
falling but the debris was falling and
hitting him on the head
shoulders told his mom the rats were so
big
and ridiculous underground
she added that anyone could have fallen
where her son fell
the family is considering legal action
in the wake of the incident
what are you gonna sue the rats that ate
out all the [ __ ] below it
um new york's department of building
says the underground chamber is a
seller next to the mostly empty
five-story building officials ordered
the building to be vacated after the
incident
and they are looking into the seller to
see who owns it the building owner was
also
ah there's the guy who's going to get it
the building owner was ordered to set up
a fence around the hole
and hired an engineer to expect the
stability of the vault underneath
the incident sparks fears among many
citizens in new york where the city has
long struggled to control
its massive underground rat population
the city's rats
started eating each other last spring as
human littered
dried up due to the coronavirus locked
and well there you go
orkan recently dubbed new york city the
third
most rat infested city in america oh no
after first place chicago my kind of
town chicago of course they are you know
they're eating good in chicago
[ __ ] best steaks in the world uh in
second place
los angeles jesus christ
i moved away from massachusetts to the
two most
rat and fest the first and third most
rat infested cities
in america that's what i did holy [ __ ]
oh my god oh my god i mean what kind of
shots do you give that guy
i'll tell you if he survives that the
way his immune system's gonna be he
could [ __ ]
that guy could cure corona just walk up
grab it by its throat and [ __ ]
stuff it back up a bat's ass whatever
you gotta do to get rid of it
um all right plowing ahead here all
right top
five dumb questions for employees
all right this is the uh oh my god this
is like blowing up here
we got medicine we got a nurse we got a
park ranger
and we got a funeral director oh boy
dear bill the out of touch mob boss burr
oh
thank you for watching that was a sketch
i did on snl which i still can't believe
i got to do
uh by the way did you see that first
sketch last night dave did
about aunt jemima uncle ben
uh the state farm guy and uh i'm not
gonna say who came in last it's [ __ ]
great
it was hilarious and i definitely seemed
like it had dave's fingerprints all over
it i loved it
all right dear okay thank you for all
that you do at the podcast it's
absolutely hilarious thank you and help
me get through 48 hours of straight
driving this year when driving across
the country
from pennsylvania to arizona and then
back again
uh the advice you have given others has
also helped me in my own personal life
so thank you
i recently listened to your segment
about the lawyer
and the top five dumbest questions he
was ever asked
i thought it was awesome and i thought
you should have some
here's some of my stories and questions
i have experienced working in the
funeral
industry in the last eight years the top
here we go ladies and gentlemen the top
dumbest questions have been
number one have you ever considered
having sex with a dead person
definitely not considering most of them
look like your grandmother
i get this question a lot maybe it is a
fair question but i think
99 of most people already know the
answer to this question and it's
completely absurd
and also if you were you wouldn't
[ __ ] answer the question
um oh my god
jesus i just visualized that
[ __ ] all right uh
you know what i was thinking of was was
that that [ __ ] movie jacob's ladder
when that thing in the tub
or was that from the shining oh my god
ah jesus christ all right we loved our
son
can we bury him in our backyard so we
can always be close to him
all right that's a dumb question but
it's also a loving question the back of
the day you could do that
we actually buried this guy in his
backyard like some frontier trail of
tears [ __ ]
i did not even know this was legal until
i was asked this
and had to find out about it i guess you
can in that state not only did we bury
him
but they did not like the vault we had
ordered him and made us come back the
next day
and take him out of the hole to put in a
sealed vault
so he would not get wet
um oh my god these are
crazy all right brace yourself for this
one number three
can you cut off my wife's favorite
tattoo on her left leg
and can i keep it sorry jeffrey dahmer
we can't do that for you
i know this is my grandmother's funeral
but can i
but can i have your number hey look at
you get a little action there
this one was rather recent i am single
and somewhat attractive male
you gotta be dude if you're getting her
[ __ ] all
her motor running in there dude but i
can tell you right now that chick is a
psycho
or has a big heart and doesn't judge
people
i don't know but i i think i covered all
the bases there
that's like that jerk off that [ __ ]
plays roulette and hits all the numbers
and then jumps up and down like he won
um
this one was rather recent i'm a single
and somewhat attractive male
but i am very professional would never p
pick up women
at work or at a funeral literally this
was a live episode of funeral crashers
if it was a show
my condolences to your dead grandmother
and family
that you clearly don't give a [ __ ] about
but i give her my number
but i did give her my number needless to
say oops yeah what the [ __ ]
um she's probably some freak that wants
to [ __ ] in a coffin
watch that'll be the third date um this
[Laughter]
this one was a comment i received from a
holy man
from a southwest asian culture
um a holy man of his religion came up to
me and said i only have one prayer to
say during
today's service i said okay oh okay
great not a problem
uh yes it's three hours long i was
stunned
and stared at him in silence only to
find out he was serious
i have tons of other stories i would
love to tell you
um if you find what i wrote interesting
i absolutely did
and i am sure myself as well as other
funeral professionals have tons of
craziness that they can write and tell
you about
every troll in the public wants to be a
funeral director
and do my job until we are called out at
three in the morning to remove a
decomposed body in a [ __ ] house
i don't think everybody wants to be a
funeral director i hope you and your
family stay healthy and
safe that's so creepy to hear that yeah
i don't want to see you buddy during
this
um yeah let me hear from the funeral
directors i want to hear some more
stories of [ __ ] weirdos
in the funeral home um park ranger
hey there billy bada bing billy bada
bing
uh i've been loving the top five stupid
questions segment recently and i figured
i should chime in
since i am a fellow masshole turned
national park ranger
um and as you may already know we have
heard it all
i work at the grand canyon so you can
imagine the types of people
we come across with over 6 million
visitors a year from all parts of the
globe
this is by no means a definitive top
five
but these are perhaps the most commonly
heard idiotic questions here without
further ado all right here we go number
one
at least once a week after driving all
the way out here
uh we're kind of out of the way passing
many signs to the
quote grand canyon someone will pull
over
pull up to the entrance and ask what's
in here
or hold up a picture of the canyon on
their phone and say
we're trying to find this i have to bite
my tongue not to ask them
how the flying [ __ ] they got all the way
out here from god knows where without
the confidence of knowing where exactly
they were
uh number two um
what time do you feed the bison or
when did the bison come out i love that
like they got a [ __ ] two-bedroom
apartment
uh the north rim has bison as if we're
running a petting zoo instead of a
national park
uh number three people looking for the
road that goes
into the canyon so they can drive their
car to the bottom and see the colorado
river
don't you think you'd see a picture or
two if the road existed sir
number four do i really have to
pay to come in this is this one is
constant as people think
uh insert burst southern accent here
okay i'll do my bad southern accent
uh this here is my land i pay taxes and
i shouldn't have to pay no
[ __ ] fee to see public land uh
there are many issues with this
sentiment and explaining them would only
further anger these animals
or people that come up and say they
don't have money to pay
and expect to be let in as if you could
sit down at a restaurant or any other
business and use this as an excuse to
enjoy their services for free
oh if you got your money no worries we
anticipated you might do this follow me
to your table
and i'll have the chef bring you out
some appetizers um all right dude
you're [ __ ] funny man you should give
these well don't give them [ __ ] you'll
lose your job
you did the right thing save your
funnier sides and send them into me
all right number five if i hike to the
bottom and can't
hike out you'll come and get me right
people expect some sort of free
helicopter ride or service out of the
canyon
if they decide to be stupid and hike
themselves all the way to the river
the sad part is if that that happened
they actually get
they actually get it on the park's dime
well we don't need to know that
except the on the parks time hopefully
that means the taxpayers dime right
i hope these were mildly entertaining
and i'd like to mention
so i don't get fired that these views
are my own and in no way represent the
views or opinions of the park service
i love everything you do and send my
best to the lovely nia and the little
birds
come out to the canyon for a private
tour any time peace love and go [ __ ]
yourself
i haven't been in the grand canyon in
forever
i went there in like 94.
all right but i've flown over at a
zillion [ __ ] times
which i feel that's i would hike down to
the bottom though
and on the way out i could do that oh
jesus bill all right
i can already hear the helicopter all
right nurse
hey billy ginger season tits
[Laughter]
ginger seasoned tits ah just in time for
october november
i'm a 27 year old rn from minnesota
registered nurse from
minnesota who works for the last five
years at i'm not gonna say where
where a majority of what we do is
colonoscopies
here are probably the top five questions
i have had
from some of these [ __ ] these [ __ ]
up patients number one
is it bad oh my god i had to read this
before i said it number one is it bad
that i've been cutting up
dove soap bars into small pieces
and putting them in my butthole to keep
the worms away
number two if i put my finger my
butthole and circle it
around during showers does it help
prevent
hemorrhoids what in the
[ __ ] people just say this number three
uh did you think my uterus looks sexy
today
we didn't check that or close to that
lol number four
does the butthole connect with my psyche
what does that even mean number five
did you see my butthole did you see my
butthole
what the [ __ ] just a medley of what
comes to mind but i'm sure you can
figure it's quite a variety
pack of people rolling into this
butthole clinic
love you the family and your sense of
humor and your sense of humor is not
like anything else by a long-ass shot
take care
uh nurse so-and-so a religious listening
lady what in the [ __ ]
did you see my butthole did you see my
butthole
wow i didn't think anybody could top uh
where is the joshua tree but they seem
to be doing it quite
quite easily here um all right plowing
ahead
medicine hey billy bleached butthole a
lot of butthole [ __ ] this week uh i work
in medicine and thus have encountered
some very uninformed individuals
as everyone needs medical care idiots
included
now i don't look down on these
individuals as they lack medical
knowledge
parentheses normal and importantly are
anxious about their well-being in these
situations
these settings sorry top five questions
statements i've encountered
in medicine all right number five young
male
adult who comes in complaining of large
amounts of bright red blood in their
bowel movements
that's scary i do a physical exam and i
cannot find an
obvious reason for this complaint i
order some tests
to find out the cause and if it's
actually
blood in his poops guy is anxious and
asks
it's normal to have some blood in your
poop right
bear in mind this gentleman said his
toilet bowl was covered in red
i had to keep a straight face and tell
him no it's not normal to poop blood
well that one's just scary and he just
wants you to say it's okay cause
he so he doesn't feel like his insides
are falling out number four
obese family doesn't know she is
pregnant
comes in the er because her stomach is
acting up
i see on an ultrasound in blood work
that she is pregnant
quite far along too but she refuses to
believe us
how do you know i'm pregnant uh i can
see the baby on the ultrasound man
wow don't you just want to rescue that
baby the second it comes out of that
person
oh my god number three okay public
service announcement
guys if you're at the doctor's office
for dick issues
just say that from the get-go don't come
in and say
don't come in and at the end say oh one
more thing my dick
also get some damn priorities if you got
the health of a laboratory rat
that has been purposely fed fat its
entire life and your main concern is
your dick
i got an issue with that
so this guy asked that the viagra i
prescribed him for his erectile
dysfunction
would also help with his short dick
he whispers this last bit i told him
no he will not add an extra inch or two
and would only help him maintain an
erection
poor bastard number two guy wants a
prescription for
ketamine this is a powerful anesthetic
explains that it is
my moral imperative to do to do this and
that i will be leaving him no choice
but to manufacture ketamine himself he
tells me the steps to make the drug
and that he has read the wikipedia page
i wish him good luck in his venture to
manufacture the truck
all right um all right opioid overdose
oh that's
that comes in via friend ambulance
so somebody drives him there pretty much
blue starts cpr
on him and give him narcan wakes up and
stabilizes
five to ten minutes after being
conscious he asked for
some morphine nah dude you were dead
like 10 minutes ago
because of that wow that [ __ ] opioid
[ __ ] my god
thank christ i never [ __ ] with any of
that
um all right well that's the podcast so
if you're new to the podcast that's one
of the things that we do on here
top five if you work with the public top
five dumb questions people have asked
you
if you live in the texas area and you'd
like to see me i got some shows coming
up
i'm in dallas uh on december 2nd i'm in
austin on the 4th and i am in houston
texas
on december 6th i just realized how big
the state is but if you're in new
orleans you can drive over to houston
maybe right
um or if you're in oklahoma you can
drive down over the red river
into dallas um all of those dates will
be up on
uh billboard.com and uh
shout out rest in peace alex trebek
one of the greatest all-time game show
hosts of all time me and my wife
have absolutely loved watching jeopardy
over the years we totally got into it
when um
she was pregnant with my lovely daughter
and we've been watching that in the
wheel of fortune back to back
and uh alex dibrecht you know patch
sajak all those guys they're
institutions after a while when you're
on that long so
um yeah rest in peace to him
all right big shoes big shoes to fill
right there okay that's it everybody go
[ __ ] yourselves have a wonderful couple
of days and i'll check in on ya
on thursday go pat's monday night oh
geez
the two teams in the bottom of the
[ __ ] afc east the page patriots first
the jets
ah jeez